[Musique]
nous avons rejoint isabelle marie
directrice des projets stratégiques chez
jc decaux bonjour bonjour
alors avec vous on va parcourir
l'histoire du groupe à travers ces
mobiliers urbains alors déjà comment ont
évolué et mobilier urbain jc decaux
alors ils vont évidemment évolué même si
et vous envoyer plein d'exemples ici
autour de vous sur ce parc expo du
campus de plaisir
l'abribus c'est vraiment un des services
les plus développés en france et dans le
monde par jc decaux et c'est avant tout
un service donc un service qui a
profondément changé depuis 1964 la
mobilité dans les villes donc
aujourd'hui par exemple en france on a
plus 3000 collectivités locales parmi
nos partenaires et ce mobilier bien sûr
il sert à attendre le bus
confortablement
il a un design qui est spécifique et
très particulier et c'est une des
valeurs cardinales chez jc decaux que de
travailler ce design et il accueille des
fonctions alors au fil du temps il a
accueilli des fonctions par exemple
d'information voyageurs très important
aux mobilités et petit à petit en fait
il s'est enrichi d'autres services je
vous donne un exemple des prises usb
quand on est à court de batterie on peut
se brancher sous un abribus et passer
son passé son coup de fil ces mobiliers
urbains qui ont toujours leur fonction
première qui ont toujours ce design qui
a aussi son importance
a évolué pour intégrer de nouvelles
fonctions concernant les autres
mobiliers urbains parce que jc decaux ce
ne sont pas uniquement les abribus quels
sont les autres types de mobilier urbain
qu'on retrouve alors il y à des services
comme par exemple les sanitaires en
entretien automatique dont nous fêtons
d'ailleurs c'est jours derniers les 40
ans de développement chez jc decaux
c'est un sujet très important les gènes
sur l'espace public donc ça c'est une
typologie de service on a par exemple
aussi on est passé devant tels les
colonnes morris en tout cas les colonnes
d'affichage culturel
donc elle incarne la politique
culturelle des villes elles sont plus un
geste design qui est souvent magnifiques
donc c'est aussi ça fait aussi partie
des des services aux collectivités
locales et aux citoyens que nous avons
développées et alors au delà du mobilier
urbain jc decaux vous êtes aussi présent
dans les usages en termes de mobilité
douce un oui tout à fait et sur les
mobilités douces et en particulier le
vélo en libre service c'est une activité
que nous avons développée dès 2003 à
vienne puis étendu en france donc
aujourd'hui par exemple en france on
opère dans 43 collectivités locales et
le taux de satisfaction global de nos
systèmes qui est vraiment plébiscité par
les utilisateurs et de 92% donc ça
répond à une attente très forte dans les
centres urbains ont une attente des
collectivités locales comme des citoyens
pour une mobilité plus partagés plus
doux sans merci isabelle marie je vous
en prie